[Music]
welcome back to on base live in your
bleach Report app I am Mookie Betts and
today we have Mr Tristan McKenzie what's
going on brother how you doing I'm doing
very well thank you for having me on
thank uh no problem you got you got uh
your nickname is like Dr sticks where
did that come from
um dang first question out of the gate
first question Dr sticks and
uh I got that from my friend Todd Isaacs
I was just with him the other day and he
was getting on my nerves and I told him
I was coming on here and I was like
they're probably going to ask me about
it I'm not name-dropping you because
you're getting on my nerves and the
first thing you do is name driving I had
to that's my guy he gave it to me early
on in my in my baseball career I've
always been skinny uh and growing up my
nickname was Doc because I wanted to be
a doctor I was kind of smart and he just
kind of threw the two together and it
just stick I made it my name on
Playstation I made it my name for pretty
much everything so what kind of doctor
did you want to be I wanted to be a
heart surgeon a heart surgeon yeah so
you know how long you would have had to
be in school for that
still and you was ready he was ready to
do what so
where where'd the doctor come where are
your parents folks doctors where did
this doctor thing come from uh so I mean
both my parents are in the in the
medical field uh both my parents are
rptas uh but I don't know I just always
enjoyed helping people and I always
wanted to be involved in medicine in
some way and I figured the best way to
do it would be to like to start at the
source and start the heart and
yeah I mean so you said you you're kind
of smart like you gotta be real smart
for that though like so you do you think
you were smart enough you I mean I think
you could have made it yeah I mean I
think so I mean I think it was if it's
something I'm passionate about I'm gonna
go get it so you're gonna do whatever
yeah all right shout out to Tristan for
fixing the people man
um real quick there was a uh
weather out in L.A was was rough
um
so hopefully everybody's okay out there
it rained a whole lot to me it was just
like a big rainstorm maybe because I'm
in I've been in Florida and you know you
see all the Hurricanes that kind of come
through there so but uh hopefully
everybody's doing all right we lost some
power too man I mean I saw the picture
of Dodger Stadium yeah the Dodger
Stadium the picture of that it was it
was crazy I wonder if it was real though
you know I don't know because the next
day was it was perfect and it was still
raining so I don't know I mean maybe it
was maybe it wasn't doesn't matter I'm
just glad everybody's doing all right so
um we're gonna play this game called on
base off base bro
whether you in or out you kind of seen
this show so you know what this means so
what about are you on base or off base
on having a baby named after you
foreign
did you ever see the situation I uh I
kind of put out that situation man it
was kind of crazy I'll take you guys
through it I did in the video already
but
it was weird man this guy was just
yelling at me and he wasn't like being
annoying or anything he was just yelling
and he actually wasn't even really young
he was just talking loud you know and uh
he just said
you know name my baby after you I think
he said it twice and
I don't know what made me want to say
something to him but I just told him nah
man
and he said a little girl so that's when
I was like nah you can't do that yeah
and uh he's still he stuck to it man
shout out to Mr Giuseppe you know I
really like his name too Giuseppe that's
a sickness but I mean I think it's like
it's off base for you because it's kind
of a weird situation but I think just
the idea of it and like him wanting to
do it and then you kind of pulling
through and hitting the Home Run and
then him going through with it I think
that's so on base I think it was like it
was like the coolest coincidence
of all time you know um but it was cool
it was good and you know
have a goddaughter or whatever she is I
don't know what was that what that would
be a goddaughter I don't know how a
family tree would work in this situation
since I was kind of you know thrown in
there but you know we'll do what we got
to do right take care of the kids all
right what about uh taking your gaming
set up on the road on base on base what
what the are you a PC guy PS4 guy I mean
PS5 guy what are we Xbox One we're
talking uh so I haven't had my
Playstation with me in a minute but I
play on my laptop and I know you're a
big Apex guy so yeah yeah Apex yeah
you're Apex guy too right yeah what are
your top uh top three games that you
play apex apex and maybe MLB the Show
are you playing the show too so both
apexes and then the show yeah because
there's only two games you play and you
play the show on PC as well oh you said
play on playstation yeah
so when you go do you have guys that you
play with or you just kind of get on
their solo Oh I mean honestly I I
usually play solo uh when I'm playing
the show I'll play Road of the show I'll
play Diamond Dynasty and then when I'm
on apex uh I'm running pubs a lot if I'm
with my friends I'll play some ranked I
used to run solo rank but I don't really
like this new season
yeah it's rough so tell me about the
show like are you in like a league or
anything no nothing like that uh I mean
I think I played the show more just for
fun okay especially like sometimes it
helps me get locked in on like the
strike zone or like how I want to throw
pitches sometimes if I'm bored and like
I want to face the tigers or I want to
face a lineup that we play like pretty
consistently I'll like go through it and
just figure out how to attack guys does
that tell you anything
sometimes it's not like super accurate
all the time but I think it'll give me
sometimes a general like gist of like
certain hitters that maybe I shouldn't
throw a sinker into or whatever whatever
pitches I have on the game so
it's the third inning and
five six sevens rolling around
do you say in your head
all right I start in this show I started
this guy off with a fastball away so I'm
gonna do it here in real life like did
you use the show as you're scattering
sports during the game for real so I'd
say let's say
I gotta strike out early in the game
with like a heater on the show yes okay
maybe that's something I try in game if
I'm ahead in the count and I have an
opportunity to kind of like figure some
stuff out maybe it's a pitch that
I may not use normally or maybe it's not
something that I would do normally if I
have the opportunity to do it and it's
worked I might do it
um
I don't even know what to think about
that don't worry I'll be practicing so
oh man I need to show to change my my
rankings on there to do so we can't give
him a Scouting Report okay what about
what about penciled painted bats on base
or off base on pencil painted bats I
thought I thought I think it's kind of
on base it looks I did you see Bryson's
back yeah I thought it was cool so they
got to use whatever bat they wanted for
for that game and it seemed like it
seems cool I haven't I haven't ever been
there during the Little League World
Series have you gotten gotten to go so
we played the Angels there in 21. tell
me about it how is it so what goes on I
know you're riding down the the uh it's
not a slide I guess it's a hill it's a
little Hill yeah and you got the
cardboard and everything but I do
cardboard you probably had to get I did
not go down the hill something uh it
started so it started raining and the
grass was slick but like still a little
sticky and I tried to go down and almost
tumbled and I said yeah that's that's it
for me okay so what else did you what
else did you get to do uh I think the
biggest thing was just interacting with
the kids the energy there is insane I
mean because I think even as
professional baseball players we kind of
watch a little bit of the World Series
because you see a lot of those kids uh
so just being a part of that because I
never played in it so being a part of
that and being able to like witness it
like firsthand was super super cool the
Stadium's super dope uh and then the
kids were just having a ton of fun just
being able to see professional baseball
players so it made me feel good to know
that like even though it was my that was
my rookie year uh that they knew me and
then I got to kind of be a fanboy of
show hey and Mike Trout and there were
some other guys there yeah did they
share pins you know how the the pins
that the towels do they give pins or
anything of that nature I don't think
they did pins there didn't do pins I
don't think so where do they stay do
they stay do this like a hotel I don't
even know oh so you didn't you just yeah
it was literally we showed up to the
field uh and they had so there was
multiple Fields there so we got to like
walk around and interact with some of
the kids but a lot of it was like uh
based in like the barracks where we were
so okay okay and it was really nice the
the facilities and everything is really
yeah I mean it looks super dope I just
had I've never seen it
just figured no no it was super nice
okay so okay let me ask you this
Switching gears
ice cream are you in or out on ice cream
I'm out
how uh it's just not for me I'm off base
you lactose
oh I think so maybe maybe a little bit I
don't think so is that what are you just
don't like this taste of it
I don't like ice cream
it's ice cream so so I'm not I'm not
actually lactose but when I was in
elementary school I didn't like milk and
I used to tell them like I'm lactose
intolerant so they wouldn't give me milk
and pretty much from like I had a bad
experience with milk when I was like
real little and then from that day I was
like I'm off everything no milk what is
what is a bad experience with milk
because the only thing is you drink it
and you put it in cereal I uh I drank it
and I threw up I don't know if I drink
too much I don't know if they gave me
something I didn't like but I threw it
up and I was just like yeah I never want
to touch that stuff again so and then
and you know it goes in ice cream and at
that point I was just like I didn't want
anything to do with it so
no milk no eggs no cheese but I still
like eating pizza and like other stuff
okay so you're not all the way out on
I'm not all the way out but milk but
your ice cream ice cream I'm out okay
shaking my hand what about
Major League major league is the best
baseball movie you're in or out on base
or off base on that
um
off base for me what would be your your
favorite baseball movie sand lot sand
lot sand lots like my all-time fave
something about the something about the
Fourth of July scene and being a kid and
enjoying the game of baseball for like
the very basics of it is it really hits
home for me so how many times have you
seen Sandlot
a lot of times oh a couple of times I
wouldn't put it over 10.
have you have you really seen Major
League like gotten to really really see
it I think it's a very good movie I
think the bass out of here yes have you
been to the field
uh no I have not
but I'm pretty sure our first base coach
or our third base coach Mark starbaugh
was in Major League or major league two
he was in the movie he was in he was in
one he was in one yeah I don't remember
where he was at in the movie but I think
it's not your favorite movie Man
me and Sarah were close though but it's
not my favorite movie all right okay so
let's switch gears bro so you've been
hurt for a little bit how is everything
coming uh coming along uh I mean I've
been feeling good uh we're getting
closer and closer hopefully I can throw
in some games by the end of the year uh
being optimistic about that and I mean
it's tough not being on the field but
just being able to be in the clubhouse
in any capacity yeah so what do you do
what do you do like you know I mean
because you go go and do your rehab or
whatever and then after that you know
kind of what do you do just hang out
yeah I mean it's it's for me once I'm
done with my rehab it's like I'm a part
of the clubhouse again I get play cards
play Mario Kart with Jose shoot
basketball uh be the biggest cheerleader
I can be I mean I think for me being
able to affect the game especially as a
starting pitcher I'm not able to go out
there and throw every day so when I'm
not able to play it's it's hard for me
to to not be locked in but it's also
easy for me to just be like this is what
I have to do anyway so and so
do you feel like that is a very
important piece that
teams need yeah I mean I think it not
gets overlooked but I think sometimes
you're not able to affect the game how
you want to all the time so I think
being able to be consistent with your
energy at least when you're not playing
is huge to not only yourself but to guys
around you because they know they can
kind of rely on you in that regard yeah
I think so too you know playing playing
every day and then having the starters
that
aren't playing making you know making
sure they're in there and they're
cheering and whatnot because the game
kind of you know we play so many you
know and so sometimes the Energy starts
from you guys so kudos to you for uh
for doing your part you know especially
being a younger guy
but that could be like you said
overlooked a lot so it's super important
what about
um and what's been the hardest part so
far about going through the rehab other
than not playing right
not playing that's it uh I mean I think
I think mentally trying to take a step
back from the game is is the hardest
thing uh just because I feel like you
want to be involved in so many ways but
like being able to like take the step
back and be like this is where I have to
beep be where my feet are I think a lot
of times when you're playing you're able
to be like I'll get them tomorrow I'll
think about what next month looks like
what's All-Star break looks like uh what
the end of the season looks like where
are we at are we two games back are we
ahead you're able to like look kind of
ahead and I think rehab forces you to be
like I'm here for this game I'm here for
my rehab today uh and it just kind of
puts you in a place where like you have
to be present yeah and that's that's
I remember I got getting hurt and you
really
maybe the other perspective is because I
play every day and so it's good to kind
of take that step
back and just kind of enjoy it for a
little bit and yeah enjoy you know
because do your point like yeah we are
always looking to tomorrow and when
you're hurt it's like I just want to get
out there tomorrow you know what I'm
saying so it's just it's a it's a
different perspective but you know for
you it's like
you only you play every fifth day and
then so you really you could be like I
want to get out there some more I want
to get out there some more and so you
know my perspective was I'm trying to
sit down somewhere you know what I'm
saying I'm gonna sit out I mean
understood understand you know but it is
what it is you know it's different
perspectives but both of them you know
we want to play so let me ask you this
bro
you tweeted out
something about a Rolex and Stroman tell
me about that situation oh is that it
right here that's it right there tell me
about that situation yeah you know what
I'm saying
and you're right-handed yes and you are
your Watcher in your right hand uh after
my second injury I'm dedicated to
becoming left-handed and I also heard
you're supposed to wear it on this
recipe because of how it's set up so
um I've been I've been wearing it on my
right wrist uh before we find out about
this situation
how you just say you're going to
dedicate yourself to becoming
left-handed like how is that what how
does that happen it's it's not super
easy but I've been like focusing on like
trying to eat left-handed and when I was
little I used to I'm kind of I think I'm
like kind of ambidextrous when I was
little I used to shoot left-handed
basketball so it's not super hard for me
to pick up I swing a golf club
left-handed
um so it's trying to find a balance and
just so right now Tristan you a lefty
I'm trying to be yes you're uh okay
outside of baseball throwing Lefty got
it okay so now tell me about the the
Rollie uh so I was in a meeting with my
parents uh and we're talking to this guy
and he has a Rolex on in the middle of
the meeting he's got a fluted bezel and
we're talking we're talking I'm just
looking at the Rolex and I my dad bought
me a nice watch uh he spent like a
couple hundred on the watch and I love
the watch to death
um but I'm like dang like I really want
to Rolex I've been in the show for like
a year and some change like I want
something that like I can spend some
money on and feel like it's mine and
like it's like a nice little piece and
he's wearing the Rolex I'm like dang I
really want one sneak out pull my phone
out I want to Rolex with a fluted bezel
mm-hmm there you go right there put my
phone away sit in the meeting for like
an hour get out and I checked my phone
and my Twitter's like blowing up I see
stro tweeted at me oh I'll get you a
Rolex if you do this this and this and
I'm like
hmm
yes
that's nice in theory but I mean I guess
we'll see and I'm showing my parents and
I'm like all right we'll go out and do
it did you think he was serious or you
thought he was just kind of talking
I mean I didn't think he would tweet it
out if he wasn't serious but then again
like I didn't really believe him right
okay but I mean in the back of my mind
all year I'm like I gotta do it just
just see it yeah just to see okay all
right uh and I had talked to him uh
prior we had had like a couple
interactions but nothing like super
serious nothing nothing to say okay
nothing that was Rolex worthy in my mind
okay nothing that was Rolex worthy
um but then we got to
I think I'd passed the 160 inning Mark
or I was at like 155 or 156
uh and he texted me and was like yeah
bro the Rolex is on the way because I
was I was clear under the era goal and
he was like yeah bro the Rolex is on the
way send me the text uh he had the
Jeweler set up and literally just sent
me a picture of the watch and I was like
wow
this is this is real so what'd you do
what'd you do when you got it like what
was it what was it did you just
immediately put it on and you just it
was hard
he was walking around like ain't nobody
tell me nothing
well the first thing I did was take a
picture and send it to my parents
he came through
you came through so he came through
straws that kind of dude though yeah I
mean as you know obviously now yeah very
uh I mean I was super thankful about it
I took a ton of pictures of it I didn't
wear it for probably like
a week I left it in the case opened the
case and would just like wake up and
look at it and be like wow so were you
thinking uh where's the first place I'm
gonna wear this no I I mean where was
the first place you wore to the field
and then I was just like I don't know
compliments on it
uh
uh a lot of guys didn't even notice
immediately because we see each other
every day so it's pretty hard to
and then I started I started flexing a
little bit like after that after like
the first day I started going
[Music]
you got to do what you gotta do man so
and now you wear it every day yeah and
now it's just a part of it it's just a
piece yeah so when you pop out
this is it this is the piece when you go
to the field roll your own yeah go to
the grocery store Rolly on Rollie is on
yeah all places phone wallet watch
rolling got it okay so
help me help me talk about changing the
culture of baseball because I know you
and you've been doing your part and can
you kind of catch us up on all that you
do do in the community to help change
the culture of baseball oh I mean I
think up here alone I try to just this
is this is a perfect place to do that
exactly you know there's plenty plenty
around I think I think Cleveland fans
love their city in terms of like they
love their sports teams and I see it a
lot from just the love we get day in and
day out let alone like when we pitch in
the playoffs and and just it's a ton of
fan support but I felt like on my end I
could have been doing more to to kind of
give back to them I feel like they give
it so much to us being able to like
share the game of baseball with the city
uh in places that maybe don't get to see
the game on on a regular basis or
whatever it may be so I mean currently
now uh throughout the summer every
Friday when we have fireworks I invite a
group of 20 kids from the boys and girls
club uh to come to the game and just
enjoy the fireworks be able to be a part
of the game you stay out there with them
yep I'd be able to sit out there and
just enjoy the fireworks because I think
there's some something that like me
growing up is that's a fun thing to do
you go to a baseball game you get a hot
dog you get a drink you watch the team
win and then afterwards you get to watch
fireworks it's dope and they put on a
great fireworks show so it's I think
it's just an experience in that regard
so just being able to share that with
people and be able to and spread that
out do you get to go to the their games
or their communities and watch their
their games or
be a part of what they got going on in
their areas instead of coming to the
Guardians field a little bit of both so
I mean I think a lot of the guys on our
team are involved in the RBI program so
we'll go there I've been involved with
boys and girls club I've done a baseball
camp at the Boys and Girls Club of
Cleveland up here
um I think just being able to to at me
as a as someone that they see on TV as
this great star baseball player but
knowing that like I come from humble
beginnings uh and that the game of
baseball gave everything to me and I'm
trying to spread that wealth with
everybody else and let them know that
like you don't have to be LeBron James
to be the next guy you can you can give
back in in any way so let's start from
those Beginnings so you from
Jamaica so my family's from Jamaica from
Jamaica born in New York and then raised
in South Florida you do they speak
Patois yeah do you no I mean it's it's
English
no it's not it's Pat's what it's broken
English English I mean yeah it is it's
the only thing only thing I know is
wagwan what's up we'll go on that's it
that's the only thing I know because I
went I've gone to Jamaica a couple times
and I've asked them to speak Patois a
couple times and I just when they start
speaking fast it gets a little confusing
I don't understand nothing they're
saying so but your family does yeah so
my dad was born over there uh he didn't
move over here until he was in his
teenage years uh and my mom was born
over here but she used to go back there
every year so my grandma's got like a
heavy accent okay uh so a lot of my
family members are from over there yeah
and was it is there baseball is there a
lot of baseball there not not a ton I
mean they play a lot of cricket they
play a lot of soccer they run a lot of
track
but not baseball no not really baseball
so how did you get introduced to
baseball so my dad moved here when he
was a teenager he moved to New York and
he was a huge Yankees fan uh and he used
to just watch all the games so growing
up that's what we used to do I used to
sit on the couch or we would sit
together we just watch baseball all the
time it was your guy I was a Derek Jeter
fan okay big DJ fan and so you started
playing baseball he put a baseball in
your hand and you just kind of said I
doubt I want to play baseball
um so we moved down to Florida when I
was young and he wanted to get me into a
sporting wanted to get me doing
something and I had always enjoyed
baseball so I started playing baseball I
played a little bit of basketball like
seven eight but I didn't like it people
sweating and like rubbing up on me and I
just I like I like my space
I was tall and they started to ask me I
was like nah I'm okay so you didn't play
any other sports all baseball just
baseball yeah so your pops he didn't
really play baseball right no who around
you played baseball that helped you
get to where you were now get your where
you are now
I mean it was really just me I mean my
dad was my coach pretty much growing up
and how did he learn to coach like if he
didn't know much about baseball how did
he learn he said so what he tells me is
when he watched when he watched baseball
you have these commentators who are
ex-baseball players who really know the
game right he said he just paid
attention he used to like all the
information that he gave to me was
pretty much regurgitated kind of
simplified to how he thought I would
understand it but give me information
straight from guys that he thought knew
the game really well and obviously you
had your other coaches that would help
as well so have you always been a
pitcher uh I mean I played other
positions growing up but I'd say I
really started like pitching heavy heavy
uh
at 14 but I mean I was always I was
always on the infield in some capacity I
played Short in my freshman year and
then they moved me to first base because
I was tall could you hit
not really I mean I could hit a fastball
my average in the show was 500. how many
wait one for two one for two I only got
two ABS in this show as in like in the
big leagues in the game on the game no
no in the beginning
I don't know about you so and then you
you play Summer Ball you start getting
when did you start getting like looks
from colleges
uh
I'd say I went to like my first college
Camp after my my freshman summer but I
didn't really like gain steam until my
junior summer going into my senior year
I didn't commit until like the month
like July before my senior year and you
committed to go to Vandy yep what had
you been to Nashville before uh so I
went I committed like right after I went
on my visit up there like my unofficial
visit that was your first time going to
Nashville and what what made you love
Andy I mean it's a great City oh you're
you're a Tennessee guy yeah I mean
that's that's my spot
um I mean so for me I I visited other
colleges I tried to stay close to home I
went to some colleges close to home I
visited Miami and it was nice but there
was just something about Nashville it
was for me far enough away from my
parents to where I had some space
um but also like they're coming off
winning the national championship so
from a legacy and a great baseball
school and me wanted to be the best
baseball player I could be it was a spot
for me and then on top of that it's a
great University and Nashville the city
was just warm and inviting
um I just loved everything about it so
it was and what other
um places had a chance
I talked to UVA for a little bit uh I
talked to Miami
uh I'd say those were honestly probably
like my big three did you go on your
visits yeah I went to UVA and you had
the most fun at the Vandy one so so it
wasn't like my official visit it was
unofficial
coaches uh
I knew somebody that had gone to UVA and
I I liked it but it just it just didn't
feel like the right setup
uh I didn't not that I didn't like the
coaches but I wasn't really vibing with
them with how like when I went to
Nashville everything just felt smooth
and easy he's awesome yeah awesome they
do they do it right there yeah so what
and you got drafted
was it hard
saying no like saying no to college
yes uh I mean I was especially with your
folks being in the medical field yeah I
mean they probably pushing I mean I'm
not necessarily pushing for college but
college is probably the right way to go
I mean I think I was almost on the fence
almost for me leaning 60 40 to try and
go to school but my parents were like
this is what you wanted this is your
opportunity and I think at that point I
was just something like I can't I can't
turn my back on baseball at the next
level if this is really what I want to
do right right and so you started your
minor league career how was my leagues
for you oh I honestly I really enjoyed
it I think it was almost a year by year
case for me in terms of like I started a
rookie ball and then I went to short
season and I went to low way then Haye I
was hurt the following year but went to
double a and then I was hurt the whole
year in 19 and the year that I was
supposed to be in Tripoli and hopefully
like make my debut and then the next
year was covet so it was kind of weird
but I mean I enjoyed the time I think
the bus trips teach you a lot about like
who you are as a person being able to
like live on your own being able to like
figure out what you're gonna eat calling
my mom every day and be like Mom like I
don't want to eat Chipotle again she's
like well you either need to learn to
cook or you need to go back to Chipotle
you need to figure it out uh so I think
like for me it caused me to grow up a
lot so understanding like what that does
for a player and how it made me who I am
today I really enjoyed it what was the
first thing you bought
after I got drafted after you got
drafted
2007 BMW
well you didn't want to get a new one I
didn't need a new one
I just wanted something that I could I
told my parents when I got drafted
because I didn't drive in high school I
didn't get my license until I was like
18. I thought you what what happened you
just my mom used to drive me to school
he's chilling the passenger seat oh okay
all right all right you do what you got
to do yeah uh but I told him when I got
drafted I said I don't I don't care if
it's new I said I'll take a Toyota
Corolla S I just need an aux cord and
some Bluetooth I just want to be able to
listen my music and you didn't want that
in high school
or you didn't care about it I mean I was
it was a 15 minute drive to school and I
didn't really I didn't really I'm not
gonna lie I didn't do much outside of
play video games to play baseball
um
and you I guess I mean I
I'm the opposite man I'm trying to get a
car immediately me and my homeboys
though you know we this is you know we
got the aux core we rode around tried to
talk to girls and all the other stuff
you know what I'm saying that's how the
wife came into play you know you know
sneaking off sneaking off and we got got
you know but it is what it is so let me
let's switch gears some more man bro so
you you've been around a lot of Legends
Miggy for sure he told I think he said
something to you uh not too long ago he
was glad you're not gonna pitch no more
yeah I'm saying he was glad about that
how it how is it getting to face some of
these Legends people that you saw
growing up you know getting to talk to
these people learning from them how like
CeCe you were with CeCe the other day
yeah right how is it getting recognition
from them because they see they
obviously see something in you yeah I
mean I feel like a little kid all the
time when I'm around them like it's just
because I feel like it puts me back in
that mindset of being like I'm watching
TV on the couch with my dad and I'm
watching Miguel Cabrera on TV or I'm
watching CC pitch uh so for me in that
regard it's really cool and then I think
on top of that like being able to
compete against Mickey and like almost
like going head to head and facing him
is like another step in the milestone
for me and then being able to converse
with him on the field and have him like
almost talk smack to me be like oh [__]
are you pitching today no okay good good
and like it's it makes it's like very
fulfilling for me what about for your
pops because you know he's watching it
he watched the Yankees and
I I even though he didn't just see the
Yankees he saw a lot of guys and so now
he's seeing these people come up in your
face and I'm like is it cool for him too
I think for me just I think well more
for him like me just being in the big
leagues is everything that he could ask
for being able to watch me on TV being
able to like I think through the miners
you miss a lot of games you miss being
able to like be a part of it I think him
being able to like watch every game I
think he watches every game or at least
he watches a broadcast he watches the
opposing broadcast he listens to the
radio he watches each game like three
four times oh okay so does he tell you
is he is he oh yeah that's that's my I
mean maybe not coaching we have like
discussions it's more like why'd you
throw this pitch Oh I thought this this
and this or this was the plan he goes oh
well I thought you were going to do this
and I thought you're going to do this
it's almost the same conversation we
used to have on the TV like growing up
and be like oh like what do you think
he's gonna throw here two one what do
you think he's gonna throw here three
two so do you ever get mad not mad but
like that I know I shouldn't have thrown
that picture with it you know what I'm
saying like is it ever that uh I
wouldn't say mad but sometimes like
let's say I throw let's say I beat a guy
with a heater and I'm O2 and I go I'm
gonna get fancy and throw curveball and
I give up a homer or a double yep he'll
come back after and be like what do you
calling that curveball I'm like oh man I
can't even say anything back I just
gotta let him I just gotta let him have
his things so have you ever thrown the
pitch known throwing the pitch and said
dang that worked on the show
and then turn around be like I know my
dad gonna say something about that later
on all while on the mound yes I've
thrown I've thrown a curveball and
gotten it hit and been like dang that
did not work like how I thought it was
gonna work and be like I'm gonna hear
that later and how does that make you
feel like is it like oh
I'm not trying to hear it or or no I
mean no it always comes from a place of
Love yeah for sure he definitely staying
there from that and so I bet I bet your
dad he probably keeps a journal of stuff
and says you know what I'm gonna ask him
about that I'm asking about that I'm
asking about that he writes himself down
for sure
good for him and your mom your mom does
too that she does she not question you
but like ask you about no my mom just
asked how I'm feeling did I feel good on
the day or did I feel bad she just might
she she knows she just leaves you alone
because she knows if I have a bad game I
don't want to hear all the the details
that's what mine is different than moms
and dance yeah so she but she's there
she's watching they watch every start do
they how often do they get to come
oh they were just I mean
a couple times a year uh they like to
come to a lot of the East Coast trips
they don't really like to fly a ton they
like to drive so like when we're in
Tampa or Baltimore or I think next year
if we go to Atlanta when we're in Miami
that whole East Coast they're gonna
they're gonna be there
okay so tell me about tell me about some
of your routines like when they come
oh we'll say when they're not there when
they're not there you don't have anybody
there tell me a routine that you got you
wake up in the morning you eat breakfast
or you sleep in late it depends on how
I'm feeling I think if I do go get
breakfast I like to go get me a nice
bacon and egg no cheese okay no cheese
yeah bacon so sometimes you like cheese
sometimes you don't it's on it's it's
like very specific it's only on like
Italian food if it's like baked so like
a baked ziti a pizza
but like I ain't going to eat with you
what do you mean yeah you you we got to
go somewhere specific for you no you no
we don't I like your tummy hurting man
so tell me about the routine you wake up
in the morning I'll go get me some
breakfast I'll go get a bacon and egg on
an everything bagel yeah
um and usually if we got to be at the
field at like one or two uh I'll either
hang out on the start day for you on a
start day
um
nah I'll just honestly I like to get to
the field decently early I'll get there
like hang out yeah I like to be I like
to be in the clubhouse and be around the
guys and like almost because on start
days I'm I'm like I'm Ready for War okay
so you're not you don't talk no uh no I
like to talk I'm like I bubbly energy
like I can't contain it like like and
anxiety yeah but you get it out by
talking not by being quiet no no if I'm
if I'm quiet something's wrong okay
usually the only time I'm quiet is like
if I got the bubble guts or something
um
I mean no no honestly I'm probably
letting them know like y'all stay away
and somebody's acting up a little bit
all right um but if not you're talking
playing you know playing I'm hard I'm
shooting basketball I'm playing on the
start day oh yeah okay I I like to I
like for me I want the guys to know that
like I'm here I'm I'm active like I'm a
part of the team like I'm not just
because it's my start day I'm not hiding
in the corner focused on this like no
I'm still here uh like I want to let you
guys know like I'm ready to I'm Ready
for War and it's not it's not a
different day for me okay so what time
do you eat do you eat at a certain time
no so everything usually on start days
I'd like struggle to eat I eat I like to
eat early and then just chill for the
rest of the day and then okay so then
you just kind of like eat some nuts or
something like a snack to get you
through anybody anybody in our clubhouse
especially if they have the camera on me
and I have a cup in my hand there's a
snack in there chips cereal
on start days anything oh any day start
you you start days I'm not eating oh you
don't eat but on nine start days you eat
all day
okay so what time do you start going
outside when you're starting to throw uh
I'm a little out of practice so I gotta
I gotta think back okay usually I mean
I'd say an hour before the game an hour
and a half before the game but I'd say
like for my for my prep routine I'm
starting out at 4 45 ish I'm getting in
the tubs I'm relaxing a little bit I get
out I might play a game of cards I'll
pull off and then I go stretch
and then I'll come back I try to like
kind of space stuff out a little bit you
don't have you don't have anything
that you're like hard set on like
I try not to like super like you don't
have any like real superstitions but do
you have things that okay I gotta do
this though so I'd say outside of the
field no when I'm in the lines like I
have a certain way that I run out to the
mound every time I have a certain way I
walk off the mound I put my glove in the
same spot so when I'm physically like
playing I have superstitions but before
then I try not to take anything but with
me I try not to feel like
maybe not what I'm eating but like
anything else affects my game
okay
so
do you when other guys are starting or
when other guys
are
doing whatever like do you
do you go talk to them do you support
like what how is it
when other guy like and I'm asking from
from me right now like when other guys
are starting because I've seen Chris
Sale
he would when on his start days he would
go get all go get all the pictures and
go upstairs and go do something I don't
know I was
on the field so I have no idea like do
you guys do that do you have any
pictures that do things like that like
would you be there for them I mean
obviously you wouldn't be there for them
but do you have things like that oh I
don't think any of our guys have like
it's like a little ritual that they yeah
right I don't think anybody has like a
super strict like ritual like that where
they need anybody else involved I think
Bieber is probably like the strictest
one like he goes he goes very about his
business but I think it's more just a
timing thing than anything I don't think
anybody has like a set food that they
eat or anything like that how is it
learning from Bieber because you know
he's been there I guess you know your
whole career yeah and he's been I
obviously dope his whole career right
yeah how's it learning from him oh I
mean it's cool I think I think we have
kind of he to me feels like an older
brother but we go back and forth uh in
terms of just like communicating on what
he feels on on how he pitches uh I think
I try to learn from him a lot just on
how he executes how he attacks guys uh
figure out like how he throws his slider
to guys and like what's his thought
process and how he goes about his
business because he's very good do you
have the other guys that you lean on uh
I think I think I try to for me I try to
pick from everybody because I think
everybody does certain stuff very well
um so I love like Cointreau I love his
his like his energy on the mound and I
think for me consistently being able to
ask him like how do you almost get to
that point where like the game feeds him
and then he gets to a certain point
where like you know like oh nobody's
touching them today or Bieber has this
thing on the mound where like for me I
know when he's locked in because he does
this little like I call it the horse
trot he looks like a thoroughbred he
starts to do this little like back and
forth Pace on the mound when he's almost
like waiting for the hitter like oh I'm
ready so I just I think there's like
certain things that I'm like oh well if
that's what kind of gets him into his
rhythm or what does he do that that kind
of gets him into the flow of the game
and I'll try and almost steal that do
you but what about guys on other teams
do you use do you talk to guys like
straw or C or Edwin Jackson or do you
know I mean I try I haven't I haven't
really picked their brains a ton but I
try to watch how they how they attack
guys or more just
I'd say like how they go about their
business on and off the mound or like
how they enter how they how they act
like in The Dugout or how they interact
with their teammates and stuff like that
that that to you is more important than
the actual
throwing of the ball is what you're
saying I think for me I think baseball
is a team sport and I think as much as I
can affect the game by throwing the
baseball I think if I'm lights out
that's one thing right but
how many times am I going to be lights
out right so I think for me being able
to like affect the game in other ways or
let your team know that you're there if
I'm having an okay day and they can tell
because my rhythm's off or I'm not doing
something proper or I'm not I don't look
myself they can let me know and I think
it goes vice versa is it is it a thing
for pitchers because hitters we go talk
to each other
you know a lot yeah and you know we talk
hitting a lot and we talk you know just
the game a lot because hitting is hard
you vary even though the you know we're
on separate teams if any of we still
talk is that a thing for pitchers yeah
definitely I think more though I think I
when I talk to other guys I talk pitch
design or I talk like thought process on
like how they throw certain pitches or
what they're thinking to get a ball do
to do one thing or another and have you
have you heard some off the wall things
Off the Wall things not off the walls
like wow that is a really roundabout way
to throw a slider
oh no I I try not to judge anybody's way
of thinking because I think we're all
different and you you we all get to
either the same place or a different
place in like slightly different ways or
in the same way right and so
when you have you ever tried learning
the somebody let's say somebody
gave you a new grip for your change up
or whatever
have you tried it yeah has it worked no
has not worked has not worked I I've
tried it did you give it a fair chance
for it to work though what's a fair
chance like through it for a game no I'm
not throwing it in the game unless I
trust it
um okay so they didn't even make it out
of the bullpen no
how do you know if it's gonna work
uh
uh because I don't know you know I mean
I don't I don't want to find out
actually I try to stick to my guns okay
so and pitching
as you're growing up like who taught you
all the the did you just learn how to
grip the ball and all these things or
was it just like I'm going out there
messing around with the pops and all
those type of things so it was growing
up I was fastball curveball change up I
threw all three of those up until I got
to the show
um I added a slider in 20 at the off
season of 2018.
um and
I think like my changeup was so my
changeup was really good up until I was
probably like 15 and then my Velo
started to tick up a little bit and my
chained up got bad and since then it
like hasn't been good do you use those
same grips from being a kid same
fastball same curveball uh I chained my
curveball a little bit I was like on the
two seam and now I'm like a little
higher but same thought process same
everything yeah good for you bro good
for you well it's super it's super dope
to see
to finally get to meet you because we
hadn't gotten to meet no I'm not gonna
lie we went out to LA last year
I think it was like I don't remember we
were out there for Father's Day and you
weren't in the lineup I was like dang I
didn't even get to see mookie I didn't
see you out on the field yeah I I
had my ribs I think was yeah it was
broke cracked yeah so you I don't even
know if you were there so we missed you
that was different there but I was
probably getting some rehab done and and
chilling you know probably taking me a
nap or something but yeah it's finally
good to get to really meet you bro so
all right so we got
um there's this game that
I I think you enjoy and you you name
things right you just name random things
okay
no I'm asking you dude is that what you
do do you name your shoes or name your
name your car well now that you got a
car yes right name your car
what what is what is the name of your
car Stella Stella why why do we come
with with Stella uh how did we come up
with how do we come up with Stella I so
currently I so my original one the black
one her name was Monica I don't know how
I came up with the name okay uh my new
one I got a white one her name is Stella
she's like bright like a star the star
and Spanish is Estrella and then I went
with Stella
okay all right so so do you name do you
have you name your hats do you name
shoes what is it like these got to be
big things that are namable more
personal items so like my chain her name
is Jackie
ha
how how do we come up with Jeff
where did Jackie come from so two four
flipped is 42 I was a 42nd overall pick
in the draft Jackie
okay all right so what's roly's name
Artemis
Artemis yeah or Artemis a Greek god yes
okay so what what color scheme I don't
know silver yeah silver is Artemis no my
bag's name is Griselda
Griselda
how do you how you uh girl Zelda how you
say Griselda oh that's that's a Jamaican
Patois yeah okay so what how did how did
Griselda come in come into play gray and
Spanish is Greece and then I just held
it's a name okay great so I named I
named some of my gloves because they
mean a lot to me but outside of that
name something in your glove so let me
let me hear the glove that means the
most to you uh uh the glove that I got
from the perfect game All-American Game
it was a black Rawlings with like some
some Camel lacing his name was Ace
but I use that probably from I use that
my whole senior year and then like
probably my first two years in the
miners but now he's he's set up at home
he's got his own he's got his own little
corner do people know that you name your
gloves Ace my family I try not to tell
everybody but I guess it's published
I haven't named my current glove
but when you do like nobody in the
clubhouse will know the name
who do you tell like why do you name it
if you're not going
hey can you go in and grab Ace for me or
can you run and grab go to Zelda I mean
I would do it so right now uh
I don't know actually I just I think
it's it's more for me like if it means a
lot to me and it's something that I feel
like I'm going to use every day
I'll name it and I think it's kind of a
cool name like my glove so last year I
had all Red glove I called it Ruby yeah
it's obvious yeah something some
something simple that that fits that
fits whatever it is so that people know
you can't really try that hard on Ruby
no
you just gave that you you gave up on
Ruby dog you got to give Ruby a better
name just just you think I mean I mean
she's a gem
I used to throw gems with her
I guess Ruby I feel like you didn't
really think about it you just I mean
sometimes it's just that easy sometimes
it takes a little more thought process
but sometimes okay I mean you do what
you got to do that your gloves you know
what I'm saying they they yoga so let me
I want to ask you this bro
because for the people out there that
don't know there's a responsibility as a
black player in the MLB
um that we have and you know it's kind
of to give back to our communities to be
um that light
that um
some people may not have you know some
and and so how how is it how do you deal
with that like what do you do to help
you understand
that you have this
responsibility and how do you take
action to it uh I mean I take a lot of
pride in just being a black baseball
player knowing that there's not a ton of
us out there in at the major league
level uh and I think for me
representation is huge I think
when you look at a CC Sabathia or I
named Jackie Robinson uh I think he's a
he's just a major part of
my identity as a black baseball player
knowing that all that he had to go
through just for me to be able to be in
this situation uh and understanding that
I almost take that same responsibility
for those that come after me because
they're looking at me they're looking at
everything I do how I go about my
business on the field how I go about my
business off the field
um so just trying to be a role model for
them in that regard and understanding
that they're looking at me regardless of
pretty much in every way
and so even
even when you don't pitch well and you
see
your fans and and the supporters like
how do you
you know what I didn't separate separate
you because it's hard it's hard to know
like dang I didn't play well but
in the stands bro you got
a hundred little kids that love you and
adore you and you need to go say hi to
them no matter how you like how do you
separate the two uh I think you have to
I think for me I have to separate like
the competitive nature in myself from
the game of baseball from a Fan's
perspective they're seeing the team and
they're seeing me as this athlete who
goes out there and competes but win or
lose I'm still that athlete right for me
win or lose I'm either a winner or a
loser in some regards and and sometimes
that's not easy to deal with but
understanding that the kid didn't see me
as a winner loser he just saw me as a
major league baseball player right he
just saw me as a guy that was out on the
field playing right and so
you do understand that
you have a long time with this too right
you got to strap it on be ready
hopefully because it's going to be hard
to do especially you know I'm gonna be
with you for a long time we're going to
change the culture right but you know we
got to make sure we do our part and like
you said helping the communities and
always being there no matter what always
being accountable no matter how good bad
whatever happens and so I just want to
make sure you know that you know you
already I know you got your head on
straight I appreciate your doctor and
everything so you know you thank you
smart so you play the immaculate grid
right
I so that means yes can we pull it up
please I attempt I honestly I got Tito's
help the other day and he gave me like a
point a point zero yeah he's a
dictionary when it comes to baseball
that it's not fair can we please pull up
the immaculate grid because uh it's
gonna take us a while to to do this I'm
terrible at them no I I can give you
I can give you one that's Jose Abreu the
first one is Jose Abreu
easy but that's going to be that's going
to be a big number though are we just
doing it to do it yes yeah absolutely I
haven't filled one out uh so I'm trying
to get all of them with above 50 Jim
tell me for uh Sox 500 career homers
yeah yeah there you go
Cleveland Legend
okay
um you see he's got the Hat on I know
right
uh what about played for the White Sox
and the angels I'm not gonna lie you're
on your own from here on out I told you
I got one square
you don't know any of them I got nothing
golly okay uh I'm not gonna I didn't
watch a lot of baseball growing up I
played I like like I used to watch oh
you know this one though
with 40 homers hmm hmm there's one right
now show hey old Tony
there you go
um
I don't know who a oriole with 5.4 500
homers
oh I'm Houston Houston 40 plus
that should be Houston Houston uh
uh
who dang this might be the worst matchup
I'm horrible at him I am horrible at
these things I don't even know who
played for the Orioles and the angels
Orioles and the angels Orioles and the
angels
um yeah you're no help I'm I'm telling
you at all
40 home run season and 500 homers I mean
I I don't even know how the people I
guess uh David Ortiz
who's hit a 40 home run season has 500
homers
nice uh three percenter that's a good
one
hello see we're going for the the low
percentage you know the low percentage
now and honestly none of them so I'm
usually better at like the 500 career
homers or like the 40 40 years 30 30
years but like the teams I'm terrible
because I I don't know what come on with
the 40 home run the Houston then oh
500 homers that play for the Orioles
that's what I don't know
that in my head too
wow my bad Eddie
I said that man we got four guesses
I Houston in 40 homers I just don't know
I'm gonna I'm gonna try for the teams
now
because I'm giving up I'm drawing a
blankets coming up
angels and socks oh you're done did you
or Don ever hit 40 homers
right on our breath wouldn't surprise me
I feel like he made that yeah let's try
and see no he never did hit 40 homers
huh
shaking my head
I don't know who played for the Orioles
and the angels I hope nobody's judging
me for this either because I'm bad oh
yeah we're getting judged so you might
as well embrace it
um I don't know that I want to yeah you
want to give up I don't think I know any
more of them can we know some of them
Trey Mancini I guess oh I should have
got you a leader before Jeff Bagwell
Network oh
and Trumbo Trumbo played for yeah he did
play for both Angelito is he he's on the
uh which cause now huh I forgot all
about that I should have got you a
little
Geo you don't know me but I'm sorry
dang Frank Thomas
yeah I'm shaking my head well
we got some fan questions now
um first question who's better at Mari
Mario Kart you or uh Jose he's he's zico
he like he'll like purposely fall into
eighth in the second lap just to get a
lightning and then like a star and then
you'll get blown by and you'll be like
what are you doing like he'll be in
first slow down go to the side let you
pass him and then come back out and then
still beat you so is there's an art to
being
really good I mean I'm sure there's art
to being good at everything right I
think if they had time trials on the one
that we have in the clubhouse he would
set the records it's because he he gets
the stars all the time or does you know
the the uh I don't know the shortcuts or
what so well so really and truly we like
play this one like uh cup over and over
and over
and I don't think I've ever beat him
I've I think I've won a couple of races
yeah but like in the full cup like I get
dusted every time
okay all right um so let me ask you who
who do you mostly play with when you're
playing the show
um I like to play online a lot and if
I'm not playing online no like who what
team oh guards oh
I like to I like to pitch for myself or
pitch with Bieber uh and if and if it's
not that Atlanta or I like to use show
hey
you show hey huh not the Angels just
show him just show hey okay
so sure
that's how Cody is he just said you show
Hey Okay so
let me ask this bro because obviously we
know what happened but a week or so ago
or is it are we can we joke about it now
do you guys joke about it is it
something that's left alone Jose doesn't
like it he doesn't like joking about it
he doesn't like it at all he didn't want
to be in that situation it happened yeah
he didn't want to but I mean I think so
uh we gave so the the Tigers were here
and we honored Mickey because this is
he's retiring this year we gave him a
nice guitar and Jose's holding the
guitar and he goes to give him the
guitar and maybe like does this little
like square up with him and Jose is just
like
I want no parts uh so he didn't even
like the joke you know so you can't joke
with him man God
he goes oh yeah get the hug and then he
goes haha Jose's like
immediately he didn't like it so Jose he
he didn't want he didn't want none of
that I mean obviously didn't anybody
want that to happen but yeah so it you
can't don't joke with it he's like super
non-confrontational and he doesn't want
it like being brought up over and over
like he's like it happened it is what it
is it's behind me I don't want no parts
okay all right well it is I won't joke
with him I won't joke with him then so
anyways bro thanks for coming on man
um I'm sick we didn't talk no Apex yeah
uh Apex see this is a problem I got two
kids and now that the second kid is
alive and doing well it's hard for me to
get on the video game and be a dad and
try and get my golf swing right and get
my bowling game right you know and this
podcast it's a lot it's a lot that's an
Uber athlete yeah I try how many how
many sports did you play growing up uh
four
yeah I played four and I played all of
them until I couldn't play anymore
so
um yeah so I try and do all of do all
that you juggling a lot yeah I'm used to
it it's a lot still tough the kids is
what what is uncle and everything so
okay um you know you can wait if you if
you if you don't worry I'm playing video
I'm I'm gonna be on for a while okay
well you know what we got uh Tristan
McKenzie here thanks for coming on the
show I'm super excited to when you have
kids I'm curious to hear their names bro
so uh shout out to your kids your future
kids anyways thanks for coming on here
and uh we'll catch you guys later on
foreign
[Music]